The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
today, we really kind of talk
more about the system, the
kind of third direct innovation
factor, and then about
these indirect factors that
are important and significant,
but not as powerful, I'd argue,
as the direct factors.
But first, let me just
recap last week just really
in a few seconds,
and then give us
a glimpse of what
we're getting into.
So last week, Robert Solow,
the great growth economist,
developed-- really
created growth economics--
developed the theory that
the dominant causative
factor in economic
growth was, quote,
technological and
related innovation,
a phrase that you'll
hear all the time here.
And then we followed up
that discussion with talk
about Paul Romer and his
work on human capital
engaged in research as a kind
of second key direct innovation
factor.
That's the talent base that has
to be behind the R&D system.
We read Dale Jorgenson who
told us that, yes, in fact,
this innovation based
economic growth model
is in fact correct.
That's what happened
in the IT wave
and he showed us, in
effect, how that occurred.
The model was you do an
invention or a core group
of inventions, they
begin to scale up,
applications pile on them,
they enter into the economy
and really begin to
scale up in the economy.
And eventually, over time,
become a true innovation wave.
And we'll talk more today, as
you know, about innovation wave
theory.
We also read a piece by
some Merrill Lynch analysts,
and the fundamental
point in that piece
was that industry is very
interested in innovation,
but they're only prepared to
fund the very short late stage
of it.
So somehow, even though
the evolution to innovation
is a very long-term process,
the financial sector
is only going to
dive in as close
as they can to certainty--
in other words,
at a very late stage.
So those were kind of
our four core readings.
And one other idea in
that Merrill Lynch piece
was this notion that
innovation needs
to move through a series of
stages to kind of get there.
There needs to be
an early vision--
kind of a visionary who will
set out what could happen.
And then enabling
technologies evolve
that become technical
enablers for the evolution
to an innovation wave.
And then there's going to be
substantial talent on task.
In other words, people have
got to be-- researchers
have got to be working on this
in significant depth in order
for this thing to evolve.
So it's going to take a
community scale kind of effort.
So the first class
left us with two
direct or explicit
innovation factors.
And we could in a--
oversimplify them and
put them in shorthand,
but we could say
you've got to do R&D
and you've got to have a talent
base staffing that R&D system.
And we worked on a definition
of innovation as a system
for introducing
technical advance,
and we talked briefly about
innovation waves, which
we'll spend more time on today.
So that's a quick recap
of last week's discussion.
And Chris, you and
I can follow up
so you catch up on some of
the issues that came up there.
And I've posted the slides
to the STELLAR site which
will help as well, but I'd be
happy to talk to you further
about it.
So let me just do
a quick snapshot
to open up today's discussion.
So that's Thomas Edison.
That's his idea factory
and that's the group
that does the light bulb.
It's the light bulb
and you can see
the idea factory-- this building
in that scheme at the top.
And then you can
see the farmhouse
back behind which
is where Edison
lived with his wife except that
he never spent any time there.
He was in the idea
factory pretty much 24/7.
I just want to give
you a feel for what
innovation is like when
it starts to take off.
And this is a good--
Edison is a classic example.
So he-- very limited education.
He was homeschooled
by his mother.
He's probably pretty dyslexic.
We don't quite know that,
but it's probably the case.
As a kid, he understands
the early evolution
of the telegraph and he develops
kind of a newspaper sales
scheme during the
Civil War where
he gets the newspapers
ahead of time in Cleveland,
gets them out to the trains
coming into Cleveland,
and then sells
them on the trains.
And he's kind of kept--
in other words, he kind
of beats the news cycle
and then unloads newspapers on
these early commuting efforts
as people are coming
into the city.
He gets his big
break by scooping up
the child of the
telegraph operator.
So trains had to operate
by telegraph systems--
they were a crucial technology
to enable trains to work.
And the telegraph operator for a
train system is very important,
but also obviously serves a
larger community communications
purpose.
So the kid of the
telegraph operator
is down on the tracks--
train is coming down the tracks.
Edison, as a boy,
sees what's happening,
rushes, scoops the child up,
barely escapes the train.
Needless to say, the
telegraph operator
is appreciative, so he
trains Edison in Morse code
and how telegraph
operations work.
So he becomes an expert on
telegraph, which is obviously
early electrical technology.
And he becomes a master
at it, and then he
becomes very interested
in technology itself.
So over time, he
goes to New York--
he develops what
becomes, in effect,
an early stock
ticker, which can--
what we would call multiplex.
In other words, you could
receive multiple telegraphing
signals and communications
over the same line, which
obviously was a key enabler
for keeping track of stocks.
So he becomes very close to
the scions of Wall Street,
including JP Morgan.
He gets to know them all
because he's like their enabler.
And then he sees this thing
in Ansonia Connecticut.
It's not-- it's a much
bigger version of this,
but there's this
kind of gimmick--
these nine foot tall
polls with a spark,
because they're
positive and negative
a spark travels across--
looks really cool.
People are wondering
around-- they
don't know what to do
with it, but they're
awestruck by this kind of
electric movement of lightning
going across the two poles.
Edison has the idea-- oh, light.
So he takes the-- he makes
his money on Wall Street,
he takes all his money out.
He goes off into a farm
in Menlo Park, New Jersey
out into this rural area.
He hires this team which
consists of an interesting mix
of artisans--
like, there's an incredibly
important glass blower here,
which heralds back to the
MIT glass lab which I always
buy stuff from.
And there's also
scientists and engineers
in here, but a lot
of people who just
know how to do things
who are very good at sort
of mechanical tinkering.
And it's an interesting
team, and he
has to take this idea
of this weird arc
that he saw-- these nine
foot tall couple of poles
that he saw in
Ansonia Connecticut
and turn it into a light bulb.
It's not an easy job
and it's very intense.
There's only a certain
amount of money--
the money is going to run out.
He's gotta get this thing done
before he runs out of cash.
And they work
literally all the time.
They're always on it but they're
having the time of their lives.
So there's a wood
stove in here over in--
I'm not sure-- maybe
it's in another corner.
But around midnight, they all
gather around the wood stove
and they're--
rap music has not
been invented yet,
so they do doggerel verses which
they throw at one another--
insulting and funny and
this incredible doggerel
verse back and forth going on.
And they all have big cherry
pies and apple pies at midnight
and gather around the stove.
It's a very intense effort.
And actually, Edison
is away for so long
from the farmhouse which is
further back on the property
that at one point, when he
comes in at like 2:00 o'clock
in the morning, his wife
pulls a revolver on him
thinking he's an
intruder because she's
seen him so rarely.
Fortunately, she doesn't shoot.
But there they are gathered
on the idea factory,
and eventually they come
up with the core concepts.
The vacuum tube
obviously is core here
and the right
filament is core here.
They come up with a working
model of the electric light.
There's only one problem--
there's no electrical system.
There's no nothing.
So they've got a
wonderful application
for a nonexistent system.
So the real innovation here
is not simply the invention,
it's creating the whole system.
So they have to envision--
they have to think of what
an electric utility might be.
They envision the
utility, they envision
what a generator would be.
They have to think through
all these early safety
requirements.
So it's an incredibly big
thing that they're launching.
They're launching the
electrical system, not simply
the light bulb.
But the light bulb
is the enabler
that's going to enable
them to sell the system.
Eventually, they do
a big demonstration
on a couple of city blocks in
New York-- everybody loves it.
Gas lighting is
not what you call
optimal since you have a good
chance of blowing yourself up.
And the nation
eventually switches over,
but I just wanted you to
see what that innovation
moment looks like.
And we'll talk about
great group theory,
and this is certainly
a great group.
But that's the moment
we're after in this class.
That's the moment we
want to understand.
We want to understand how
that innovation emerges
from the group, but
importantly, how it scales--
what happens to it.
So that's kind of a little--
that's story time
for today's class.
Now we'll do serious work.
I want to get some
other basic ideas down.
So we talked about some
basic concepts last time.
I want to put a few
more on the table.
Steps in the technology
development process.
So we talked a
little bit last week
about three of those
steps, but let me put them
into a larger context.
So typically,
you're going to have
to go through a
series of steps here
to actually get to really
scaling a technology up.
We talked last week
about having a vision.
about supporting
enabling technologies.
Then you're going to do
your particular invention.
Idea-- you're going to need to
do some research to perfect it.
You're going to need to
develop a prototype of it.
Then you're going to need
to go through engineering
development.
Then you can start to
think about production,
and manufacturing that
prototype, and then
eventually scaling up to
commercial production.
You've got to have a supporting
infrastructure system
and there may be additional
applications that you
can use and pile on here.
And then you've got to go
through a series of generations
of the product.
So that's a lot of
stuff to get through.
So the US typically thinks
about innovation as, like,
in the vision idea
research realm,
but it's a much
more complex process
that has to be mastered to
actually get from the discovery
to the innovation.
So there's models for
technology change,
and we'll talk more about
those in a later class,
but just a couple of core ideas
to put on the table right now.
Technology push-- so we talked
a bit about the innovation
pipeline last week.
Technology push is typically
where you support research,
something emerges from
that research in effect,
and then enters into
widespread use--
typically a
commercializable product.
So in effect, you're nurturing
and developing a technology,
and you're pushing it
towards the economy.
Technology pull, or
sometimes called demand pull,
is a different model.
So in this case, the market
will create an opportunity.
The market may create
a niche or someone
may spot the opportunity
or the niche.
And in effect, the
market is going
to pull that technology out--
is going to be, in
a way, the enabler
for that technology to evolve.
So these are two very
different processes,
and we'll talk more
about who does which.
There's incremental innovation
and there's radical innovation.
So incremental innovation--
as a definition here,
it improves function,
aesthetics, performance,
efficiency, manufacturability
and so forth.
In other words, modest
incremental steps.
It's very important.
We all kind of love
radical innovation,
and there's actually
good evidence
that radical innovation
will lead to a really
disproportionate profit impact.
In other words, if you can
launch a radical innovation,
the gains can really
be big, and that
will become an important idea
when we talk about venture
capital later in the class.
AUDIENCE: From what
year to what year
is that-- is the
scale of that graph?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Now
you're calling on me
to really look closely.
I don't know how many years.
This is a '97 study out of
the Harvard Business School,
and I just don't
remember, Martine,
how many years this covers.
But I'll be happy to
look that up for you
because I don't see it on here.
But it's gotta be at
least a 10 year look,
I think, to be meaningful.
So I don't want you
to get the idea though
that one is better
than the other.
That incremental or radical
are better than one another.
I just think-- the Wright
Brothers aircraft would
be a good example of
a radical innovation,
but you and I would not want
to take the Wright Brothers
aircraft across
the Atlantic Ocean.
We would rather do the 787.
So incremental can be
extremely important.
Historically, industry
does the incremental.
That's more of a technology
demand kind of model--
a technology pull
kind of model--
as opposed to the
radical, which tends
to be more out of a
technology push research base.
And we'll talk more about
those things as time goes by,
but I wanted to get
those out on the table.
So although radical
may be more profitable,
incremental is easier,
and obviously, there
is much more
incremental advance.
Max?
AUDIENCE: Regarding
the technology push,
is that more funded
by governments
and big institutions,
universities, or?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes.
Because in our system, as we
talked a bit about last week,
research is predominantly
funded by government
and the actors are
universities, and development
is predominantly
funded by industry,
which tends to be a more
incremental advance.
And there's something also
that you just kind of need
to keep in the
back of your minds,
which is product cycle theory.
That products go
through cycles--
go through evolutionary stages.
So a firm defines a product,
it develops a market for it,
then it standardizes
the product.
And then typically
over time, one design
will tend to dominate.
And then the number of competing
companies with varying designs
will tend to shrink.
And over time, the
product will sometimes
become a true commodity product.
High volume, the price
goes significantly down,
and the profit margin
is much lower, so
the uniqueness of the
product kind of ebbs.
At that stage in the US
system, the production
often goes offshore.
That's the moment where it
occurs where the commodity
production begins.
Barriers to entry
increase at this point
because only a modest number of
firms on a standardized product
tend to dominate.
And the surviving firms
have to have the capacity
to keep advancing
their technology,
keep making
incremental advances.
They've gotta be able to
master large scale production,
they've gotta have strong
distribution and marketing
arms, and they've gotta
have the management
talent to kind of work
across all those pieces.
Matt?
AUDIENCE: Could you
explain just briefly
how you go from the number of
competing companies reducing
[INAUDIBLE] commodity
[INAUDIBLE]??
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
I mean, think about things
you see all the time,
like search engines.
How was it that Google really
came to dominate the search
engine business?
Or think about
operating systems--
how was it that Microsoft really
came to dominate the operating
system world?
So that's just--
consumers tend to lock
into the dominant product.
How was it that apple
came to dominate iPhones--
Although that's obviously up
for grabs every few years.
It's not to say there
can't be entry of others
into these fields, but
the barriers to entry
tend to get higher because
how many firms can really
master all these skill sets?
That's pretty sophisticated.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was just thinking
about, like, I
would expect stiffer competition
to lead to that commodity
market where you have
a lower profit margin.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
So you really have to
systematize the operation
to be able to continue to make
strong gains out of that more
commodity product line.
And then typically,
you've got to keep
driving the costs down as well.
Now this is not
eternally true, and you
began to poke at some of
the problems in this model.
You can think about ways
of disrupting this pattern.
So for example,
some companies are
learning how to do continuing
radical innovations.
That was-- Apple is a
good example of that.
That was Apple's magic.
It does the Mac, and
then it does the iPod,
and then it does the
iPhone and so forth.
In other words, it's
able to continue
to do pretty radical innovations
on a continuing basis.
What enables a company to keep--
that ability to keep innovating.
Because it's not--
there are only
a handful of companies in the
world that are over 100 years
old.
They burn themselves out.
Globalization obviously
spurs competitiveness,
and it spurs entry and
increased competition.
It speeds the
product cycle, so it
can be disruptive of this
traditional product cycle.
There may be-- and we'll talk
about it more in our next
class--
but a kind of rebirth
of manufacturing process
improvements that could disrupt
this cycle and change it.
And there's now a very
interesting service sector
that's not hard-product
based that's emerging,
and the possibility of
tying services to hardware.
So an Apple iPhone
is a classic example
of a hard technology that is
also a service delivery model.
So we're getting
these combinations
in interesting new ways.
That will change this
product cycle as well.
So it's not a eternal, but I
want you to get an idea product
cycle theory.
And then our final idea before
we dig in on the readings--
dynamic versus static
competitive advantage.
So David Ricardo, great
economist in the 19th century,
develops essentially a theory
of static comparative advantage.
That advantage would be
intrinsic to a country
typically based on
natural resources,
and his famous
economic example was--
and we talked about it
a little bit last week--
but England has a lot of
rain, has a lot of grass--
it can have sheep, it
can do wool very well.
And Portugal doesn't have
that much rain, doesn't
have that much grass, but
it's great for growing grapes,
so it's going to do
wine, England will wool.
Each has a natural
comparative advantage
based on a resource advantage
and it benefits both to trade.
Portugal expands
its market for wine
by growing outside
its own borders.
England expands
its market for wool
by growing outside its borders.
There's a benefit to each.
So that's the kind of 19th
century concept that's
the heart of free trade theory.
That's a static
comparative advantage.
Starting around the middle
of the 20th century,
something very different
began to evolve.
A dynamic comparative
advantage, and this
is based on growth theory.
In other words, if
you can be innovative
and you can lead
innovation waves,
you can capture a lot of the
early gains of that innovation
wave.
It's Solow innovation
based growth theory.
So that is a dynamic
advantage created by--
and we have to understand the
menu-- but investments in R&D,
and education, and
efficient governance,
those could all be inputs--
and we'll talk more about
the system later today--
into a dynamic
comparative advantage.
Now a dynamic comparative
advantage is not eternal--
it may get lost.
And we're going to
talk about some work
by Paul Samuelson who laid
a lot of that thinking out
in a famous 2004 article in one
of the next couple of classes.
So the US created, in many
ways, the biggest innovating
economy in the world coming out
of that World War II period.
So it built a
competitive advantage
based on innovation, which
had been evolving in Europe.
And countries like
Britain and Germany
had been doing something
similar starting
in the second half
of the 19th century,
but the US really scaled that
model up and really built
a very strong early
stage innovation system.
It became the richest
nation on earth.
That was its model, that was
its comparative advantage.
Now the problem with a
comparative advantage
based on innovation
is that others
can figure out how to innovate.
England is always going to
have rain, and sheep, and wool,
and Portugal is always going to
have sun, and grapes, and wine.
Those are inherent, static
comparative advantages--
they are not going to change.
An innovation
advantage can change.
So the US had an incredible mass
production system coming out
of the end of World War II.
Japan figures out a
better innovation model
based on quality production
and takes consumer electronics
and large parts of
the auto sector.
So that's how a comparative
innovation advantage can erode.
So it's powerful-- you can
get very rich as a nation
and as a society--
but it's also up for grabs.
Anything so far on this?
Any questions so far?
All right.
And these slides will be
parked on the STELLAR site
and accessible to you.
So these underlying foundational
ideas will be around for you
to glance at.
So today, we move to our
discussion leader system,
and so here's how
it's going to work.
I'm going to talk for
10 minutes or so--
12 minutes,
something like that--
about the readings.
And then each of our
able discussion leaders
is going to in turn
take that reading.
So Beth has got Nelson
and did you have Atkinson?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Beth
somehow got the really two hard
readings.
I don't know how she
lost in the jump ball.
But lily will take the
next couple of readings,
and then Martine will follow
up with actually the really fun
stuff as we get towards
the end of the class.
So we'll have to make sure
we find full time for it.
But let me start with Nelson.
And he's our third grade
growth economist-- a Columbia
professor of economics.
And he writes in 1993 this
really interesting book
about national
innovation systems--
a comparative analysis.
And he essentially
puts out another--
a third innovation factor.
So we've got Solow's and
Romer's, and Nelson really adds
a third.
He develops this term
national innovation system.
He's not the first
one to use it.
An economist named Chris Freeman
at the University of Sussex
in Britain actually is probably
the first to use that term
in looking at the
Japanese economy.
But he in this book really
kind of spells that out.
So he talks about how the
technological capabilities
of a nation's firms and
other innovation actors
are a key source of the
nation's competitive palace.
Does the term
national innovation
system still make
sense in what is
a much more globalized world?
This is, after all, being
written back in 1993.
A lot has changed.
It is a much more
integrated, globalized world.
Is it still a term
that you can look at?
If Nelson was sitting here,
I think he would argue, yes.
He would say that enough
of the factors that
go into an innovation
system are still
tied to national investments.
That you can still do a national
analysis, but it's harder.
And we'll talk about what
some of those national factors
are in a bit.
And Nelson here uses the same
broad definition of innovation
that we've been using so far
in our first two classes.
And he refers to it as the
process by which firms master
and get into practice product
designs and new manufacturing
processes.
So it's not the invention,
it's something much larger.
So let's do some background--
some of his background points.
He argues that capitalism is
destructive and disruptive.
That's a term from a great
economist named Schumpeter.
Destructive capitalism
occurs via innovation.
It's not necessarily
the first innovator
that gets all of the rewards
or even most of the rewards.
Sometimes, the second
follow-on innovator
captures a lot of the
rewards because they
pick up from what the first
innovator's mistakes were
and improve them.
But a nation's
concern, therefore,
shouldn't be necessarily with
sponsoring the first innovator.
It's got to have
a broader concern
about innovative capability.
So again, if the
dominant causative factor
of economic growth is
technological and related
innovation as Solow
taught all of us,
Nelson goes on to
start to think about
what do you do to make sure
you're getting a lot of that?
And his point is that you need
a system to be able to do that.
A system of actors that can
be connected and influence,
and affect, and drive
your innovative outcomes.
So who are these
institutional actors?
Universities, firms,
government agencies,
and the policies around them.
And he argues that,
yes, there can
be a common analytical
framework across nations
by looking at these actors.
So this is a really
important idea that's
at the heart of today's class.
Here it is.
Innovation is a
system and you can
look at the strength
of that system
based on the strength
and connectedness
of the actors in that system.
So you can now go to
any nation region area
and you can start doing
an analysis of just how
strong that innovation
system is by looking
at the strength of the actors.
Things like the firms,
government agencies,
universities, related policies.
You can do an assessment
on innovation strengths,
so this is a key tool.
And a lot of your-- a lot
of the paper in this class
is going to be built around
this Nelson system idea.
He goes off and makes
some interesting points
about the relationship between
science and technology,
which is also really a
point about the relationship
between basic research,
and applied research,
and development, and
between university research,
government sponsored
research, and firms.
And his point is
that new science
can give rise to new
technology and vise versa.
So he cites an example
of science leading
to a technology
such as electricity,
and he cites Faraday
and so forth.
He cites chemistry as
science as a follower.
That it really came
out of a whole series
of pretty practical professions.
Some other examples.
Gibbs creates the whole
science of thermodynamics
because he's analyzing
steam engines.
That's where he
develops his thesis.
Edison is the other way around.
Edison is trying to do a
very practical electrical
technology-- the light bulb--
but he stumbles into science,
something called the Edison
effect, which actually is kind
of an early way of looking
at electron theory,
as part of that.
But this development
of electricity
yields all kinds of follow-on
scientific advances.
Aircraft technology starts with
the Wright Brothers who are--
these are mechanics,
these are tinkerers--
but then leads to very
deep aerospace engineering.
The transistor is an attempt
to solve a practical problem--
high speed switching-- and yet
that leads directly to solid
state physics--
a whole new field in physics.
Computing yields
computing science.
So it's a two-way street here.
Science can yield technology,
but technology can also
yield science.
So you've got to have that
two-way street operating, which
means that you've got
to have some connection
between the forces
in your society
that are more focused on
technology, which is typically
firms, and the research
side and vise versa.
The limits of science.
Again, innovation is not
simply the invention.
It's bigger and it
includes design.
So you engineers
in the room will
know what we're
talking about here,
but that really means choosing
the right, quote, "mix
of performance
characteristics," for example
in designing a
modern aircraft wing.
It's not enough to get
the discovery right.
You've gotta get the
design right too.
In other words, you need
to select the right mix
of performance characteristics.
Who are these innovation actors?
First and foremost-- and
this was written in 1993--
is the industry lab.
So in 1993, something like Bell
Labs, or the great GE labs,
or the great IBM labs.
These dominated, in many ways,
the industrial innovation
landscape.
They are by and large gone.
That has dramatically
changed since 1993.
Now it's not that
large firms don't
do R&D. They do a lot of it
and that number is growing,
but it's increasingly
D and less R.
Also there's a reminder
here that R&D is only part
of a larger innovation picture.
So things like management
and management organization--
organization of R&D can
have major roles here too.
So actor number one is industry.
And at the time he writes,
it's industry labs.
Now that's a much more
dispersed model now,
because industries have largely
abandoned their old labs
that used to a lot more
fundamental work to really
development processes and
rounding up innovators,
and in some cases,
acquiring them
like in the biotech sector.
But industry is still a
central player obviously.
There are also
university laboratories.
You all are familiar with those.
The government laboratories
like the great labs
for the Department of Energy
or the Department of Defense.
Then there's a whole
public sector support
system that's an actor
here as well for R&D,
and there is an
element historically
that has supported
industry R&D, particularly
through the Defense Department.
So one way to look at
this is the actors.
The actors will be different in
different industrial sectors.
They're going to look different,
and they'll be a different mix,
and they're going to
organize differently
in different industrial sectors.
So steel is really
different than aviation.
These are differently organized
things, but you can see--
you can nonetheless look at the
innovation actors in a system
and look at their
strengths and weaknesses.
Complex technologies
require supply chains,
and therefore
customers and users
play a role in the
innovation system
because there's a whole
feedback system that comes in.
So the customers play a role
for complex technologies
particularly.
So it's not only the actors
I've gone through so far.
Customers can be brought in
and users can be brought in.
So you've got much closer to an
idea of an innovation network
here, and we'll talk a
bit about Rycroft and Kash
to kind of spell that out.
So he does a comparison.
He compares the US
innovation system in the 1945
the 1975 time frame--
he compares that to
the Japanese innovation
system in the '70s and '80s.
It's a very different
innovation systems,
hence, help driving the theory
of national innovation systems.
So in that time
period, the US firms
tended to be larger in scale.
They served a
continent-sized market.
The firms spent more in the US
on R&D. The government spends
a lot more on R&D at the
time, particularly because
of the defense mission.
US university
research was stronger
as a result of some
post-war decision making
that the US made.
And most US goods were
sold into US markets.
So that's some framing
ideas around the US model.
Japan is really different.
Japan is very
resource poor, so it
has to have strong exports to
be able to get the resources.
So it's got to be an
export led economy.
Whereas the US can
organize essentially
on national consumer
markets, Japan
has got to expand globally.
R&D in Japan in
this time period--
and still pretty
much to this day--
is more tied to industry
than is the case with the US.
There's less
fundamental research.
There's much more applied
and development support
from government.
And there are, from government,
very explicit technology
development policies
at this time.
So that's just a way of looking
at two different countries
and beginning to think about
their different innovation
systems and some of
the underlying factors
that will drive them.
He argues that there's several
basic categories of countries.
Large high income, small
high income, and then
lower income countries.
Countries without resources have
to have an export orientation,
and he cites Germany,
Japan, Korea.
The US, and to some
extent the UK and France,
have a national
security orientation
for their innovation systems.
We justify a lot
of R&D investment
for national security
reasons in the US.
Other countries don't do that.
There's differences in
the governmental role.
The US government tends to
be a lot less interventionist
in the innovation system,
in the economy in general
than, for example, Japan
was in this time period.
So there are
country differences.
What's innovation's success?
Strong firms, in Nelson's
mind, is the critical factor.
They have got to do
all the translation,
moving from discovery, to
fit a whole raft of tasks
that they've got to perform
in this translation task.
So without strong firms,
you got a serious problem
in your innovation system.
But there are other factors.
Education and training,
trade policy, fiscal policy,
public support of
university research.
These are all elements,
again, in the system.
But he places the firm
kind of front and center.
And given what firms
look like in 1993,
you can kind of see why.
It's a more complicated,
complex story now.
How about an explicit
governmental role
in innovation?
How direct should that
governmental role be?
So he's fine with
the earlier stages.
He notes that there's a whole
ongoing debate about how far
down the innovation pipeline
the government should intervene.
That's been a
longstanding US debate,
and we'll get more into
that as the class goes on.
So that's our Nelson story.
And Beth, why don't
I turn it over to you
to raise some ideas about
Nelson that you saw,
and to lead us in some and Q&A?
AUDIENCE: OK.
So based on the questions that
I got from people in the class,
I kind of saw four
trends emerge in things
that we were curious about.
One being the stuff we
brought up in the beginning--
is considering a national
innovation system as a better
way to promote innovation, or
do we look at a more granular
level by looking at industries,
or at a less granular--
[AUDIO OUT]
The second main topic
area that came up a lot
was just what are the best
policies for innovation
now, given that this paper
is a little bit older.
As the world has
changed, what do
we see as the best
ways to move forward.
Third theme that came up
was technology spillover
and how that can be
used as an advantage.
And last was balancing
these national interests
versus the international
relationships that
have emerged in firms.
So just a few summary points
before we go into those.
I'll read through
some of the questions
that I thought were
especially enlightening.
Just the basis of using
national innovation systems
from Nelson's point of
view is that countries
have some similarities, but
because of their differences
in history, culture, their
infrastructure, laws,
financial institutions,
policies, and investing,
we see that there are inherent
differences to innovation
systems in different countries.
And that for these
countries to be successful,
it's not just enough
to have manufacturing--
that's not a substitute for
technological innovation.
So you need these strong firms
that are constantly innovating.
And so he comes
to the conclusion
that national innovation
systems, while they
may seem somewhat contradictory
term considering policies are
different for different
industries within a nation,
are still useful for comparing
how nations foster innovation.
And so first I
just think it'd be
interesting to hear what people
see as the appropriate way
to treat innovation systems.
Is it at this national level,
is it at industry level,
should it just be international
interactions with each other?
So I'd like to open it up
to some thoughts on that.
AUDIENCE: I think there was
one point that was made.
I think it was
[INAUDIBLE] reading.
It said, like, it
sort of depends
on the industry as to whether
an innovation system takes
place on a national level
or, like a firm level.
Certain things, like
aerospace, were often--
or defense oriented
things were very isolated
to the nation in question.
But other-- like
biotech type stuff
could be more group effort
between multiple things.
So it kind of
depends on the field.
AUDIENCE: I think it
depends on what time period
your analyzing it, because
a lot of the readings
spoke about past economic
trends and, like,
these big, long-term waves.
But I forget which
one of the readings
stated that [INAUDIBLE] a lot
of more global connection being
impossible.
The idea of a national
level doesn't make sense
as much as a global scale does.
But I guess that's
yet to be seen
because we're still sort of
in the same wave, I guess.
AUDIENCE: So you think
it might be more--
rather than trying to make
a generalization for how
innovation has
always happened, it's
kind of depending on
what kind of innovation
we're seeing that
might be how we
want to describe the innovation
systems going forward.
And then thinking about
policies for innovation,
one interesting
question that came up
was how does national
technology policy shape
the focus of research being
conducted and company pursuits?
And then going off that, how
should national technology
policy shape the
focus of research?
So that kind of comes
into that debate
of how far in the pipeline
should the government
be intervening, or
should it be kind
of a societal call for action--
where should this come up?
AUDIENCE: Well, in general,
the history of innovation,
like, early on, usually
it's not an expert
anything that does it.
Like the Wright Brothers weren't
really experts in flight,
and the reason that--
because they
weren't experts that
were able to figure out a
different way of doing it.
So probably the right
area for government
is right after the initial
is then figured out.
When you kind of know
there's something there,
and now you can start
pulling in resources.
But innovation in
general, it could
be like making a
sculpture or maybe
that you need to make a house.
So when it's time to
kind of make a house
and you need a lot
of hammers, I think
that's a good time
for government policy.
Before when it's like
chiseling, that's
better for individuals or firms.
Back to the idea of
industry being incentivized
through government funds,
in general, an industry
they'll do their own research
when they have a monopoly.
I guess if-- what used
to happen which was--
I forget what company Apple
took the graphic user interface
from, but that was all--
AUDIENCE: Xerox?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, Xerox PARC.
They were famous for
having a lot of innovations
that they could never take
to the product stage, which
is back to the
point that you made
on being able to
take an innovation
and also make it
a product and put
in some kind of
industrial cycle.
But government grants,
like SBIR grants,
are pretty good too for
creating that kind of industry
innovation, and I guess
with better incentives.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So Martine, you
make a series of
interesting points
there, and let me back to
the first one which you made.
And you made this interesting
distinction between a sculpture
and a building.
And I think historically in
the US, the attitude has--
even though logic would
say let's think about
the building-- that might be the
moment for government support--
historically, the
government support
has been at the earlier stage,
at that sculpture moment
before it turns into a building.
And that's pretty
deep in our system.
So in other words,
it's historically
been OK for government to
support basic research,
but when it gets within
range of commercialisation,
that would be a
governmental interference
into the marketplace.
So most countries don't do
that, but that historically
has been a limit on
the way in which we
think about this stuff.
So when Nelson talks about
whether there should be
an explicit role for government,
what he calls high tech
innovation-- in other
words, later stage work--
that's a controversial
topic for him to take on.
And when we talk about
Charles Schulz later,
we'll see kind of the dimensions
of this debate come further.
But what do you think?
Is that--
AUDIENCE: What I'm curious is--
so there's two
kinds of, I guess,
kind of sculpture innovation.
The only one I can think of that
was successful with government
intervention was
kind of like when
they're making the atomic bomb,
because that was very much
that we need a technology push.
But in other cases, especially
for the Wright Brothers--
I forget what the
name of the person
that the government was funding.
He was the expert in
aerodynamics at the time,
but because his equations didn't
work out, he didn't do it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, all his aircraft
landed in the Anacostia
River in big flames.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Well, the way I think about it--
they say an expert is an
expert in a field that's
already been created.
And a lot of time,
this innovator
is not going to look
like an expert at all
because the field
has not been made.
Like Edison, you really wouldn't
say use a genius in any field,
but he did figure out
something and then
he took it as far
as he could go.
But another distinction
too is that there's
going to be that are going
to team up with them.
Example with Edison is
that GE had a lot of issues
with their transmission
lines, and it
wasn't until they got this one
Hungarian immigrant called--
I forget his first name, but
his last name was Steinmetz.
He's like this very hunchback--
he's famous for never
being in pictures
because he was just very
hunchback and short.
But he came up with these
equations and he figured out
all the--
he solved all the main
problems with the technology.
So I definitely think there
should probably more study,
I guess, on that-- on when was
the government most successful
with their investments.
I don't know if they do that.
I don't really know
how the government
works with innovation
as much as you do.
But in general, VCs--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Don't worry, you'll
be an expert by the time
the class has [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Well, in general VCs
will look at their investments
and then figure out why they
won with their investment.
So that might be a good way
of looking into it-- like,
in the history of the US,
when do we make investments
and how do they payoff?
And also, like, what do
we measure the success,
because it probably
won't be economic returns
because the nature
of the problem.
But if you look at in
terms of development,
there's going to be a
lot of hidden variables
that we don't account
for that probably
need to account for when
we measure that success.
AUDIENCE: I think
Martine hit on something,
which is how does
the government choose
sort of when to get involved?
The only example I
might have is SpaceX,
because they get a lot of
support because of just the way
they transitioned sort
of out of the space race.
We have a lot of
infrastructure at NASA
who, like, no longer wants
to focus specifically
sort of on space exploration
in a way that might be private
or commercially available.
But you have this sort
of technology spillover
and all these resources
that exist at NASA.
They have a whole
bunch of launchpads
everywhere that
they can't really
take advantage of
because that's not
what they're geared
towards, and they're
trying to move somewhere else.
But you have this
infrastructure leftover,
and we started sort of leasing
it out to companies like SpaceX
to sort of do launch
demonstrations and things
like that.
And so I think--
but that only comes--
and I don't know exactly
how that came about,
but I think you might be able
to facilitate those roles,
where the government sort
of has resources built up
from things previously.
And the industry might be
moving in a different direction,
and it might see
more advantaged ways
to pass off use of facilities
and things like that.
And sort of we have--
these launchpads at NASA we're
trying to get away from--
I guess we have
national labs now
which are traditionally
more basic research,
but could be used to sort of
bring in companies as sort
of testing grounds for a lot
of different technologies.
So I think energy might
be a little bit more
useful, and even biotech
because we have supercomputers
that are shown.
But it's important
to kind of identify
that point which
technologies might
be a little bit more receptive
to sort of that branching out.
And I think it comes from maybe
one of the latter readings,
where it's, like you have to
identify who's in the market
and what are their needs.
And that conversation
doesn't really
happen because the government
doesn't get to choose winners.
But I think at some
point, it's going
to be necessary to kind
of consult the necessary--
I'm going to use the
word experts here.
And then you don't
really know who
the experts are until you kind
of bring the Wright Brothers in
if they make a jump or a leap.
But I think it could
have been facilitated
if they had brought
this guy in and found
that maybe all of
his experiments
were crashing in
the Anacostia river.
So the government would
have initially-- like, OK,
his experiments are crashing--
we need to look somewhere else
and we found the
Wright Brothers.
And so I think it's this--
the emphasis has to be on these
public-private partnerships
and facilitate those maybe
a little bit earlier.
And bringing in sort of
these industry experts who
are shifting gears to new
directions to kind of figure
out what is the best
role, because it's
going to vary sector by sector.
Because obviously, it wouldn't
do maybe the Wright Brothers
as much good if they had
access to a supercomputer,
for example.
But it might do them
good if they had access
to sort of these landing
zones or large areas of space
[INAUDIBLE] to test
flight developments
and things like that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but kind
of going back to your point
and playing devil's
advocate there,
if we're not funding the
sculptors originally,
do we have concerns that there
won't be enough that are taking
the risk on their own
to make the first steps
before commercialization?
Like, do we need to consider
that balance a little bit?
AUDIENCE: I think that's an
interesting question in terms
of if the Wright Brothers
were alive today,
would they be able to get any
kind of government support.
And then you can think about,
well, what kind of support,
or how should the government
be structured to support
that kind of innovator?
AUDIENCE: I don't think
it's necessarily fair--
I think you make very--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
I'm going to ask everybody
to identify themselves
because we're all in film.
We're all part of a movie.
So just throw out
your first name
before you start so we all
get to know each other well.
AUDIENCE: Chloe.
I think you make a great
point about the interaction
between-- in commercial space,
like between NASA and SpaceX,
and NASA optimizing
their resources
when it's not really in their
best interest to use them
all the time, but
leasing them out
to private companies that can.
But I think they do still
sort of choose winners.
Like the Wright Brothers in
the world of spaceflight,
there's a lot of--
NASA would put out a bid for
maybe a certain spacecraft
bus or something.
And then Lockheed and--
not so much SpaceX, but a
bunch of different companies
could submit proposals for how
they might fulfill those design
requirements cheapest and
the most technologically
successful.
So I think that might
not be choosing winners,
but that is sort of one
way that the government can
support some innovation
in the early stage
and maybe encourage
newcomers to take some risks.
AUDIENCE: Chris, by the way.
I think where government
has a really important role
is probably galvanizing support,
and especially initial funding,
for potentially riskier kind
of ventures at earlier stages.
For example, I know
in like biotech--
for example cystic
fibrosis, that
was a huge push by the
government and some pretty
national groups to get research
on the ground and really focus.
And it took like 10 or
12 years and hundreds
of millions of dollars,
but they finally
came up with a drug, Kalydeco
which was produced by Vertex.
So that kind of initiative
I think is really useful.
And national policies, like
for example cancer [INAUDIBLE]
or something like that, that
set a precedence and places
importance on development
of these kind of drugs
and creates some sort of
importance and path for them
to incentivize development
throughout expedited patent
approval and kind
of maybe tax breaks
or support for that R&D process.
I think those can really help
guide technology development as
well as innovation,
especially as firms
are looking what
to do next-- what
to kind of put their money in.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I think a really interesting
undercurrent and something
that I haven't really seen
any of the economics readings
talk about is game
theory and the importance
of potential cooperation.
And I really see that
as a potential role
for the government
as we move forward
in technological development,
because I think cooperation
and particularly from a
design-research standpoint,
is incredibly important
in identifying
the competitive and dynamic and
static advantages of the firm.
And I see it as particularly
being an issue in manufacturing
with robotics.
The United States is
not invested as much
in our robotics infrastructure
and now China is,
and they're poised to
become a global leader
in the next decade or so.
And it's really
fascinating to think
about the ways in which the
United States is not really
cooperating--
firms within the United
States are not really
cooperating with one another
to align their interests
to sort of dominate
international markets as well
as domestic markets.
So that cooperation can be
really important and it's not
really something that I saw
in either the Solow, Romer
or Nelson reading, is that
game theory component.
And so game theory could be
quite valuable when applied.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
great discussion so far.
You're really driving, I think,
to get at Beth's underlying
point which is what is the
governmental role going
to be in this mix.
Where do you draw
the lines, how far
should it extend down the
innovation pipeline, what are
the different controversies?
So you all have laid
out, I think, really
nicely a whole set of examples
about how we start that debate.
But that'll be a central
kind of issue in the class
as we go along.
So Beth, do you want to give
us some closing thoughts here?
AUDIENCE: So I guess
we have been viewing
this in a very much US
context, and that's obviously
what we're most familiar with.
But it is very
important to think
about what actions
other countries
are taking compared
to what we're doing,
and how we can learn from them
and best compete with them.
I guess the American system
tends to lean a little bit more
towards the kind of
capitalist free market.
Once these companies emerge,
it is seen as kind of unfair
to support certain industries
and certain companies,
while in other countries
that's more acceptable.
And it is worthwhile
to think about,
is that something
that we would want
to move towards or is it better
to kind of let these firms
fight it out on their own?
And as far as the relationship
between national interests
and international partnerships,
kind of one closing question
to consider is, how much
should the governments
be intervening and protecting
their companies versus if that
limits them from being
able to kind of function
on the international
market, such as tariffs
and other things that are
protecting industries.
Is that something that
governments should
be able to do, is that fair
if other countries don't have
those policies in
place, and are we
limiting which technologies
are successful on the market
by protecting ones that
might not be as productive?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Great closing thoughts,
and the discussion
leader system is working.
Thank you for getting
us off to a good start.
Let me do some quick
summaries and then lead
into the Atkinson material.
And Beth, we'll come
back to you in a minute.
So in last week's
class, we talked
about these direct
innovation factors.
In other words, these factors
that you really can't do
without if you want to have
a strong innovation system.
And the purpose of that would
be to drive economic growth,
to grow economic well-being in
your society in your economy.
So government plays a role in
some of these direct factors.
It supports almost
all of university R&D,
it supports governmental
laboratories,
it provides lots of support
for the education system.
And then it provides support
for industry R&D in some areas--
particularly defense, but to
some extent in agriculture.
So those are kind of--
if the Solow factor of
doing R&D is a core factor,
then you can see the
governmental role here.
But there's also a private
sector and industry
role on that initial factor.
Of course, there's industry
R&D which, as we discussed,
is predominantly D, but
that's what takes you
through the prototyping, and
engineering, and production
stages.
And then industry provides
the dominant role in training.
So those are direct
Solow-Romer factors
that are tied to industry and
tied to the private sector.
But then there is
a raft of indirect,
or we could call them
implicit, innovation factors.
So if Nelson is right that there
is an innovation ecosystem,
then there's a lot of pieces
in that complex system.
And government is supplying
some of those pieces that
have a role in the
innovation process,
but are not as direct as the
first thing we talked about.
So government is providing
fiscal tax monetary policy,
it's providing trade policy,
technology standards,
technology transfer policies.
It's providing
government procurement,
which buys a lot of technology,
particularly in defense.
It sets up the intellectual
property system,
the whole legal contracting
liability system,
the regulatory system
in many, many areas,
accounting standards,
export controls.
These all will have an effect
on the innovation system
and your ability to innovate.
But then there are
these indirect factors
that are is less critical than
the two we've talked about,
but nonetheless
part of that system.
So the private sector sets
some really important ones.
That includes investment
capital which can be angel,
or venture, or IPO, or
equity, or lending markets--
is a private sector
function obviously.
Management and
management organization
is really a private sector
function in our system.
The whole reward system--
the compensation
system for talent
is largely private sector set.
So the private sector
plays a huge role too
in this complex ecosystem mix.
So the picture I want you to
have is of a complex innovation
system.
There's direct factors,
and if we include Nelson,
we've talked about three.
But there's a whole mix
of other stuff there,
and you want to get as many of
those right in your innovation
system as you can to have a
strong functioning innovation
system.
So it's not only the actors.
You've also got to take into
account this larger system
as well.
And we'll get, in a
few minutes, into some
of the indirect factors
and how to look at those.
But first we're going to
do innovation wave theory.
That's Rob Atkinson
who's head of ITIF,
a thinktank in Washington.
We talked about-- and I
drew a scribble last week
on the blackboard, but this
is a better rendition--
what does an innovation
wave look like?
And just to recap from
our discussion last week,
there's a long build up
and that can be 15, 20
years-- it can be longer.
And then at some
point, it hits a moment
where it can start to
scale up pretty quickly
and spread into the
society and economy.
So there is a fast
growth period here--
maybe that's a decade.
Then there's a period
of more stable--
there's always a
bubble and then there's
a period of more stable growth.
And maybe that's 20
years, maybe that's more.
And then eventually, you reach
kind of technological maturity.
So the IT wave, the one you all
are most familiar with that's
still ongoing, long build up.
When do we start it from?
Do we start it from
Babbage, do we start it
from Vannevar
Bush's differential
analyzer in the 1930s, do
we start it from ENIAC--
1946, the first functioning
mainframe computer.
We can start it
at various points,
but you get a sense for
how long that buildup is.
And then finally,
we hit the 1990s
and that incredible decade
of growth in the 1990s.
This very rapid scale up.
Max?
AUDIENCE: Why is it in this
diagram the buildup is not
as long as what you
pointed out last week?
Like, last week, you had said it
was 40 or 50 years [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
It depends on when
you date it from,
because everybody stands on
everybody else's shoulders
in the innovation process.
Maybe we ought to date it
Newtonian physics, right?
[LAUGHS]
I think ENIAC is a pretty
reasonable start date,
but there's a long time
between 1946 and 1990--
it's a very long period of time.
So it's a longer
period, frankly,
than this in many, many cases.
But then after the bubble--
and in the IT world,
that's the Dot-com bust of 2001.
Then all kinds of dot-coms fail.
And then the surviving
firms are stronger
and they go on a period of
stable continued growth.
I would argue that
that's where we're on now
in the IT innovation wave.
Eventually, we'll reach
technology maturity.
The IT wave is complicated
because information
is a core organizing
principle of the universe.
It's like mass and energy--
it's one of those big things.
And if you're tying your
innovation wave to something
as fundamental and powerful as
that, maybe it's more enduring.
And we haven't begun to touch
artificial intelligence yet.
So maybe we'll get a
lot longer run, Max,
in our stable growth period--
maybe we have a lot more to go.
But think about railroads.
You can think about
somewhere in the first half
of the 20th century, we
reached a fair amount
of technological maturity,
particularly with the advent
of the diesel-electric engine.
So there are incremental
advances in railroads,
but the real challenging
period is probably
over for the time being.
Beth?
AUDIENCE: So when we're looking
at the stable growth here,
it doesn't seem to account
for, like, other things
going on in the economy.
So if we're using recent
years for an example,
you don't think about
the financial crisis
and how that's affected
the economy as a whole.
So is this just kind of a
general upward trend where
we expect to see some ups
and downs from other causes,
or have you captured
those effects?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
I mean, there's-- we could call
them black swan elements that
pop up periodically that
disrupt everything like crazy.
I'd argue that
you could actually
treat the growth in financial
services as an innovation wave.
That there were a whole
series of technological areas
of advance--
in areas like mathematics
in particular.
But IT revolution
accompanies that.
You could actually add
the technology foundation
and the processes
to really create
global financial
services system.
And you can plot that
growth, and sure enough, they
have a bubble.
The problem with the bubble
in the financial services bust
is that it just doesn't bring
down a bunch of dot-coms,
it brings down the
entire economy.
So be careful about innovation
waves in the financial services
sector-- be very careful
because it messes everything up.
But I think you can actually--
I think that one
actually works as a wave.
Biotech for sure
works as a wave.
It's not nearly as big as IT,
but nonetheless is significant.
Matt?
AUDIENCE: I think my impression
of that, reading Atkinson,
was that because the
timescale of the innovation
is so much longer than
the business cycle,
the business cycles are, like,
flips that are superimposed
[INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Very good point.
They modulate
through the process.
Atkinson argues
that in US history,
there were essentially
four phases--
for long waves in
the US economy.
So he argues that--
and different people can
look at this differently.
And look, there's big waves,
and there's small waves,
and there's wavelets
within a wave,
so it's not absolutely
straightforward.
But he argues that in the
1840s, the development
of small local manufacturing
industries in New
England around textiles
and early machines,
that's one wave.
By the 1880s and '90s, that's
regional factory based systems.
And you know what those
19th century cities look
like-- think about Pittsburgh.
By the 1940s, we're
moving towards
corporate mass
production in areas
like automobiles and aircraft.
Then in the 1990s, he
argues the new economy
which is an IT based
innovation wave emerges--
that's global, that's
entrepreneurial,
that's knowledge based.
But that's his way of looking
at innovation waves in the US
economy.
We're familiar with the 1990s--
we just discussed that one,
so I won't dwell on it here.
The political
system typically is
slow to react to these
innovation waves.
It does not see them.
John Maynard Keynes,
the great economist
who created Keynesian
theory, once
said, "practical men
who believe themselves
to be quite exempt from
any intellectual influences
are usually slaves of
some defunct economist."
In other words, they're
operating off old economics
and tend to perpetrate them.
Atkinson argues that
the American old left
was focused essentially
on a mass production
economy, which had been
eclipsed by the time the IT
wave emerges.
The conservative
political elements--
the Republican Party at the
time and he's writing in--
was very supply side,
classical economics based.
They were worried
about capital supply,
and they were
worried particularly
about marginal tax rates
affecting that capital supply.
So that wasn't organized
around an innovation wave.
That was organized around
old classical economics.
So in a way, both
parties got organized
around the two fundamental bases
in classical economic theory.
The Democratic Party around
a broad definition of labor
supply that includes education,
and health, and things
like that, and the
Republican Party
around a theory
of capital supply,
which was translated
into tax policy.
It's largely where
those parties are today.
They missed innovation
based growth theory.
AUDIENCE: When did that start?
When did that
happen [INAUDIBLE]??
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I would
say that the parties had
locked into this by pretty
early on in the 20th century.
By the time of
Franklin Roosevelt
is when the Democratic
Party locks into--
look, there's nothing wrong
with capitalist [INAUDIBLE]..
There's nothing wrong
with labor supply.
They're important elements and
they need to be considered,
and they're contributors.
We just know, however, that
innovation based growth
is the larger factor in growth,
and the political parties
haven't gotten there yet.
So a real structural
problem in the US system.
Neither then embrace
growth economics
and spurring innovation,
and that leads us
to some interesting ideas
about social organization.
So technology and
technological organization
is going to drive social
and economic structures.
So it's a really important
point that he raises here,
and it's I think
one of the reasons
why the subject of this class
is actually really important.
It's bigger than standing
up cool technologies.
It's a lot bigger than that
because this class is not only
about technology
development, it is
about the way society
organizes itself
around those technologies.
So Hagel, great German
philosopher-- "western society
is driven by the
competition of ideas."
Thesis, antithesis--
you all know the story.
Marx introduces a very different
concept into that conversation.
He argues that in acquiring
new productive forces,
people change their
mode of production,
and in changing their
they change their way
of living and they
change their social relations.
So that's fundamental Marx
philosophical perspective.
That is called
determinism in philosophy.
In other words, the
technological order
of your society will be
determinative of the kind
of society you have.
And that's how Marxism evolves.
That's the fundamental
philosophical underpinning.
And he is seeing the
Industrial Revolution drive
systematic change in
society in the late 18th
through the 19th century.
That's what he's seeing.
He's seeing this
incredible class order
evolve to match the very
hierarchical structure
that industrial organization,
driven by the Industrial
Revolution, requires
at that time.
Now, Stephanie,
you had a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
I was wondering [INAUDIBLE]--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'll get it.
AUDIENCE: --when I was
looking at the syllabus,
was are we going to
talk about it some more?
Because I guess I was
curious if you were operating
under the presumption, at least
in the lecture and the ways
in which we were supposed
to be perceiving readings
were giving us.
Like, capitalism is good, or
that capitalism is natural,
or that capitalism is something
that technology sort of--
or rather that capitalism
perpetuates technology,
technology works to
perpetuate capitalism.
When I think there's really
a lot of conversations,
particularly arising
in the last maybe
two or three years, about
the basic income guarantee
and the potential for
technology really eliminating
the necessity for labor
in [INAUDIBLE] economies.
So I figured I would
ask at this point
when it became relevant
because you had brought it up--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: [LAUGHS]
I gave you an opening.
AUDIENCE: --there you go, yeah--
whether or not we're operating
under the presumption
that the free markets are good
or desirable in the long run.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That
is really a big question.
[LAUGHING]
I guess I opened
myself up to that
by bringing determinism in--
using the excuse that
Atkinson raised the subject.
Look, that's not a
dialogue that the US
has had for some decades.
We thought the Cold War was over
and we thought capitalism won.
It's only in fairly recent
years that we're actually
starting to think, hmm, maybe
there's some more elements here
that we need to consider.
Look, I think that's
an open question.
Obviously, this class
is about innovation
and it's about innovation in
largely capitalistic systems,
which obviously is the direction
that the world economies have
gone in worldwide.
So I think that's the reality.
That's the reality we have.
My personal view is that
that's essentially a positive,
but there are
different views here.
And we have to keep in mind how
powerful the technologies that
are coming out of these
innovation systems
can be for how we relate
to one another as people--
how we organize
our social lives.
So the prevailing
technology system
really sets parameters
on the fundamentals
of social organization.
A few other thoughts
along those lines--
Kondratieff who developed the
fundamentals of wave theory
back at the beginning
of the 20th century.
He viewed depression as a
trough in a 50 year wave cycle.
Classical economists'
view of depression
was that they were waiting
for wages and prices
to fall far enough
to enable a rebound.
Eventually, everything is cheap
enough-- somebody will buy it.
Keynes took on that attitude.
This is to point back to
what you raised, Matt,
about how does economic cycle
theory interact with innovation
wave theories.
So we're right exactly at
that point that you raised.
So Keynes agreed,
but in the end he
argued better intervene
because in the long range,
we're all dead.
So don't wait that long--
better get on with it.
Schumpeter definitely saw--
who's an advocate in economics
of disruptive capitalism,
destructive capitalism--
he saw Kondratieff's
long waves theory,
but he saw them as driven
by innovation, not just
in technology, but in
the accompanying aspects.
So production and distribution.
So it's not only the
technology, but it's
the production and
distribution system too
that he would add to that mix.
So destructive
capitalism, in the end,
is based on radical
innovation as opposed
to incremental innovation,
which means that if you really
want disruptive capitalism
and the potential gains
of innovation that
can derive from it,
you've got to think hard about
radical innovation, not just
incremental advance.
So in our system,
that means in turn,
you gotta think about
that early stage R&D
too, because that's the real
contributor to radical advance
as opposed to industries
development, which
is largely incremental.
You with me?
So Atkinson argues
that technology
is the skeleton on which
an economy is formed,
and every half century or
so, the skeleton changes
as these waves come about.
The changes are not steady.
They can be very clustered.
This is not a smooth wave.
There should have been
lots of erratic lines
in the wave theory
diagram I showed you.
Now Carlotta Perez is a
great growth economist
who taught at the
University of Sussex
and worked with
Chris Freeman there,
and she argues that it's
not just the economy
changes, but the politics,
social relations, and the how
and where we live that changes.
And it's also how we organize
our education system,
and how our culture
in turn, which
is driven by some of these
factors, shapes our beliefs.
So, quote, "the logic of
the techno-economic paradigm
reaches well beyond the economic
sphere to become a general
and shared organization
common sense of the period."
So here's an idea here--
a techno-economic paradigm.
A paradigm that includes
technology, but therefore
reaches deep into economics.
So there's a driving
paradigm in a society
that connects these two.
I'll argue later in
class that the paradigm
is even bigger than this.
And that becomes, in a
way, the order of things.
So I think we'll kind
of wrap it up here
in terms of talking
about Atkinson because we
need to move on.
But Beth, you've got
Atkinson as well, right?
And I think,
actually, if you speak
into the mic in the center--
and I'll move this
laptop slightly
so you've got a
direct line there.
Thanks, Alberto.
AUDIENCE: So again,
looking at the questions
that people submitted,
there are kind
of four themes that came about.
The first being, do we
believe this is a new economy?
This whole concept
of the new economy
that Atkinson talks
about, is that something
that we're on board with?
What is the applicability
of long wave theory?
Is it something that's
unique to the US
and to more developed
countries, or can we
apply it anywhere in the world?
Are there actions
that can be taken
to minimize these troughs to
shorten how long depressions
may be?
And then a lot of
just about what
is technology's
effect on society,
and what it should we--
should the government
be doing things
to counteract technology's
effect on society
or is it a good thing that
we're seeing these effects?
So just a few points
before we go into that
that I found interesting.
So Atkinson writes
with the belief
that this new
economy is something
that is permanent--
it's not just a blip.
And I think that's
something that we
can kind of work with
as an assumption when
we discuss this.
But if you have specific
things that you can point out
that it is just a blip, I'd be
interested to hear this too.
And so the concept
of this new economy
forms new businesses,
labor organizations,
educational systems,
cultural beliefs
I think is especially
relevant today
as we're kind of seeing a lot
of interesting political things
arise.
And it says with
every disruption,
entrenched interests will push
back and may resist the change,
and so I think that's
something that would
be interesting to discuss.
So before we go into the
social aspects, I want to--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I just want to say,
Beth, I really like that--
your last point here.
In other words, we are
seeing very significant
social disruption today.
And we may be able to connect it
back to the IT innovation wave
which, frankly, the
upper middle class has
ridden to unparalleled success,
but left a lot of people
behind--
maybe.
Is that what you're driving at?
AUDIENCE: That's kind of what
I was going to talk about.
So I guess you can jump
into that actually.
So we talk about how
these long waves increase
overall quality of life
perhaps at the national scale,
but they do tend to be unequal.
So should the government
have responsibility
for correcting this
inequity, should it just
be focusing on total efficiency
for the nation as a whole,
and how can it balance the idea
that some parts of the country
may be worse off while
others are better off?
So it's very broad and open.
AUDIENCE: Could you repeat
the question one more time?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So the paper claims
that these long waves
increase the general quality
of life, maybe at, like,
a national scale.
But the benefits are likely
to be uneven based on maybe
who's most prepared to take
on the technological changes.
So should the government
have a responsibility
to increase the equity?
Should they be more focused
on just total efficiency?
How do we handle this
and the societal changes
that arise from it?
I think there is some
talk that that's kind of--
that wave of populism
has been very
evident in recent elections,
so is that something
that the government
should be intervening with
or should it be up
to the free markets?
AUDIENCE: I guess I'll jump in.
I think the major implications
of innovation wave theory
is just that we should
always be nervous
because if we don't
get the next wave,
then our economy is
kind of screwed--
we won't be number one anymore.
And so, like, some key
technologies-- or also
some examples of what could
happen in the future is,
like, there's certain
asteroid belts that are
worth quintillion's of dollars.
So if we happen to
say, oh, you know
what, we're just going to
not really focus on having
rapid innovation in Japan.
Or China says, oh,
actually, we're not really
focusing on this at all--
let's do a Manhattan
Project for going into space
and being able to mine.
And they can go in and they
can get quintillion dollars
into their economy, then their
GDP is looking pretty good.
Other implications
are say somebody
focuses a lot on biotech
to the point where
they can engineer diseases
that only they can counter.
And then they start doing
biological warfare because they
know the US has nuclear arms.
So that's a different
way they can branch out.
So I guess it's kind
of this idea of we're
never really on top,
or when you're on top,
everyone is shooting
for you, I guess.
Where we could say, yeah,
we're number one, but also
say we really need to
keep innovating and think
about how we're structuring it.
Because the future is
always going to be-- well,
time is pretty much just
indicating that change
is happening all the time.
So we probably won't be where
we're at, and we probably--
I'm thinking we don't
want to go down,
but that's really up to
the US and its citizens
to decide every
single generation.
AUDIENCE: I might come
at it from a little bit
different angle.
I think we've been talking a lot
about sort of a capital based
innovation and how that might--
the IT boom and how things
might be a little different
structured on, like,
a capital side.
We might have--
just kind of look
at the effect of human
capital and in the universe
of innovation.
But I think there's an
important piece here
where we see a lot of growth
in the upper middle class
because they're prepared
to handle [INAUDIBLE]
a lot of the sort of more human
aspects of where we're going.
But you see sort
of this transition
as we look forward into
sort of management styles
and kind of structuring
things, which is a little bit
more high level, which
again lends itself
to the middle class.
Which I think if
we were looking to,
as a corrective
measure for government
widespread involvement,
there is this sort
of public need for the
smoothing and transition.
So that, like, you see the
highs for those that are high,
but you don't see
the aggressive lows
for those that are low sort
of passed over and made
obsolete structurally
by this innovation.
And I think there's
a greater need
for kind of renewed investment
in sort of this human capital.
I guess at the end
of the '60s, you
had the GI Bill which helped
kind of a lot of folks
get reintegrated in
sort of public education
and greater institutional
or secondary education
at postgraduate increased
sort of en masse.
For a lot of different
reasons, that sort of
helped ride the wave into
the 1990s because of that.
But these sort of things
now, it's [INAUDIBLE]..
There's a lot of
different changes
that may happen a lot of more
frequently now and a lot more
connected.
So there's less room for
error because we can't really
isolate ourselves in sort
of this US national system.
But as a general
[INAUDIBLE] summary,
I think you get a lot of these
interesting events happening
a lot more quickly, so the highs
can get higher a lot faster
and the lows can get
lower a lot faster.
And so if we were sort of to
look for a governmental role,
it'd be sort of probably
smoothing out these lows
rather than focusing--
AUDIENCE: Or insurance.
AUDIENCE: Insurance-- yeah.
Investment backing and
equity capital so you have--
you're more able to kind
of take these shots.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So Rasheed,
that's really interesting,
and you're driving
us to a perspective
here that innovation
waves may be
a way, at least in the shorter
term, for the rich to get
richer and to create a
larger underclass, right?
If we look at the Industrial
Revolution, the workout
period of doing the
adjustments for the workforce--
I mean, that's a 100
year long project.
I think that recent
election results may tell us
that we don't have the kind
time to play with as we work out
the latest innovation waves.
Now is an alternative to
bring on another wave?
And then maybe all
waves are not the same
in terms of their class,
and structural effects,
and deterministic effects.
So if Martha's innovation wave
around new energy technology
that she spends her
life on comes about,
that may be a big net
generator of employment
overall as opposed to an
IT software wave which
appears to be less so.
So different waves may
have different kind
of underlying structural
features for the society.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: [LAUGHS]
Right, unless we get on it.
Martha, you better hurry up.
That's all I can say.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: What are
you saying this class was?
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
come back to a point
that Beth made right
at the beginning
when she said that we're going
to work on the assumption
that our economy is an
innovation driven economy.
And I think that all
of us in this room
are probably on board with that.
A lot of economists
are on board with that,
but then Bill made the point
that our two-party system
is arranged mostly around
these older views of economics.
So why haven't one or
both of the parties sort
of switched over into the
more innovation driven
economic theory?
And if they did,
couldn't we solve a lot
of these problems a lot better?
[LAUGHS] [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, Lilly, I'm
happy to tell you I worked
in the Senate for 15 years.
I wasn't able to persuade them--
I just wasn't able
to bring it about.
AUDIENCE: So just to
play devil's advocate,
what would that look like?
How would it be different
than what we have today?
AUDIENCE: I would say
probably the supply side
economic theory would take more
of a hit than maybe the labor
supply economic theory.
AUDIENCE: Well, if
I make a comment--
Alberto, for those
watching at home--
the thing that's been
really jumping out
at me when we talked
about it earlier--
sort of like the big old beast
of the military industrial
complex, which from
my understanding
thrives not on
radical innovation.
They really love the
incremental thing
because it can suck
out as much money
as they can from the government.
And if they can
just stay like that,
if they can convince all
the politicians to give them
money in funding of
that whole business,
that's why we're
stuck in the 1950s
because that's the system
that works best for them.
But to go back to what
Rasheed said, I think--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So Alberto, I'd
contest with you
because I think it's
fair to say that the military
has brought on actually
most of the big
radical innovation
waves of the second
half of the 19th.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, radar turned out
to be consumer electronics.
And so--
AUDIENCE: What's coming
out the F-35, I don't know.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, what's coming--
I don't know what's
coming out of that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Also
Intel is funded originally
by government.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe I'm wrong.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: No,
but it's a very good point.
And I think the
answer is that there's
different forces in the
military and there's
huge conservative
forces that want
to perpetuate their
existing operating systems.
And it's actually hard to
do disruptive innovation
in the military because it
really is a legacy sector.
So I think this play out
between how you bring innovation
into a legacy sector-- which
the military has actually solved
a few times--
is kind of an interesting
idea, and we'll
keep playing with
this idea as we go on.
So yes, the military has been
able to launch disruptive
innovation, but overall it's a
legacy sector and a lot of it
is resistant to innovation
just as you suggest.
So it's a very
interesting balance.
AUDIENCE: Well, I wanted
to go back something
she'd said about education.
That innovation waves
don't have to, like,
cause the destruction
of classes of people
as long as people are educated
with the new skills that
are associated with
an innovation wave.
Like you brought the story up
about someone teaching someone
else Morse code and how people
would not be left behind
by railroads if
many of them learned
to Morse code operators.
And then in the future, I've
just read a lot of things
about what if coding and
computational IT things become
the new blue collar
jobs [INAUDIBLE]..
All you need to do is
change the education system.
AUDIENCE: And then going
to your point, [INAUDIBLE],,
I think that it's
a little bit harder
to sell growth theory to
voters because it is long-term
oriented.
So if you give them
the option, I'll
protect your job today
versus in 10 years,
you might be a
little bit better off
because you have an agent
that's just not going to sell.
AUDIENCE: It's
also kind of hard--
I don't know.
No, actually, to your
point, [INAUDIBLE]
about connecting the legacy
sector innovation or the lack
thereof to two-party interests.
Because I think in
particular, you don't really
see modern companies
that drive innovation
sponsoring political activities
and particulary lobbying,
right?
You don't see them sponsoring
congressional candidates.
You don't see them developing
political candidate.
And you don't see them launching
political candidates out
of their own [INAUDIBLE], right?
So I think it would be
really curious to see
the ways in which this election
is now encouraging legions
of scientists, innovators,
technologists to run for office
and to see the ways
in which they align
or don't align themselves
to our two-party system.
Because if they're-- the most
important thing I think of more
in political science is that
if you're not at the table,
you're on the menu.
And so we're at
the table right now
and we all have this sort of
vested interest in the ways
in which the waves
of technology are
going to impact
not only ourselves,
individual stakeholders,
but the communities
that we're a part of
and also the nations.
Because spheres of influence
matter a lot [INAUDIBLE]..
So I think it would be
really curious to think
about the ways in which
precisely legacy sector
innovation is pushing--
almost preventing
the development
of political involvement
between innovative firms
and the two-party system.
AUDIENCE: I actually wanted
to mention one of your points.
You had said that it would
be difficult to have people
decide, OK, do you want
to save your job today
versus in the future.
Well, maybe that's-- isn't
that the purpose of government
in the first place is to
sometimes make unpopular
decisions that will in the long
run actually benefit a greater
number of people?
I mean, yeah, it's
definitely a tricky subject.
And it's not-- there's
no easy answer,
but I at least think that--
that's why we're a
representative democracy rather
than just a straight
up democracy.
It's because then we want these
people to actually represent us
and to act in our
best interests,
even if it's not
in the short-term.
Ideally, we would say
that, OK, we actually
trust these people to see
what our best interests are.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I agree that's
what I would want to happen.
[INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So I'm going
to curtail this conversation
because we have five readings to
go and we're more than halfway
through the class.
So this is going to
be a standard problem
we're going to have all year,
so we can get used to it.
But why don't we take
a quick five minute
break now and come
back, and then we'll
tackle the next round.